Are you searching for something ?
Wish you could restart ?
Well now you can
Okay, everybody who's ready to change their lives today
Join us well as you try a brand new program and face your demons today
(screams)
Come on let it out
what?
let it outttttt
ahhhhhhhh
Thank you so much
Now you're cleansing kit each kit contains four drinks that you must consume by the end of the day
The next stage will be the elimination process
Question when you say elimination process you mainly
Necessary
The cleanse you drank has expelled all the negativity from your life and put it into what you see before you
Something came out of me. That's perfectly normal. What am I supposed to do? What the hell is that you haven't seen your?
Know this can be a scary process you wouldn't believe what came out of it now. Do I get better it was smaller first
once you finish this
Won't be a beautiful thing
okay